Okay, let me use this notebook.
So as opposed to typing it from scratch.
I'm going to show you the whole thing and then we will break it
down.
I'll break down the code but
There is the we need to cover some more
we need to cover.
some
prerequisites in statistics and
multivariable calculus
I already have a video for that. So I will tell you
where to find. It's on YouTube.
I'll post a video in the slack Channel.
All right, so let's begin.
We have pandas.
Pandas is a library that extends the capabilities
of numpy.
It extends it by turning a
numpy array into a thing called
a data frame.
And it's data frames are really good
because you can convert an Excel sheet into
a python.
object
so you can see the column names of the CSV file
or Excel file or tsv file?
You can perform summary statistics.
the summary statistics
Or what actually what I should say is descriptive statistics.
So we have to descriptive statistics, which is very basic stuff.
And then there's inferential statistics. This is the most sophisticated.
In descriptive statistics, we want to see for example, what is
what are the averages the mean median and mode?
That's what we call measures of.
Central tendency like what is it centered?
and the second part of
descriptive statistics is measure of variance.
Or other measures of
this Persian.
How much variation do we have in data? If you know how much variation we
have? And what is the center of the data? We can approximate the
shape of data and knowing the shape of
data is a huge huge deal.
And if you want to know why I'll in that video.
It's a one video in that one video.
I will talk about distributions and gradient descent
and that should give you a good enough.
A review of probably talking about in
the subsequent sessions or even in here.
So we will have what pan doesn't have carers Keras.
Is a library birth on top of tensorflow basically the
abstracts away some of the complexities of
tensorflow. So if you want to build a quick simple new network,
you may you want to go with Keras as
opposed to tensorflow.
In here, we are going to create a sequential model why sequential because
we can have a sequence of layers.
input layer
a few or several hidden layers and then
an upper layer.
Of course, but we want to we need to put layers inside
this sequence. So we're going to import everything again.
The storm is everything so from keras.layers, we
will import everything all the layers.
Another important part of machine learning is evaluating the
model.
But I believe that for later.
This is for more evaluation.
We have the CSV data.
Which you I'll show you right right down below.
And I will give this file to you later.
We will import instead of using pandas.
Sorry about that. We will input the data using pandas.
And you will visualize the first five rows.
That's what the head method does.
You can see here we have.
the year built
the number of stories
the number of
one story house two story house
the number of bedrooms
the number of full bathrooms. I have others four bathrooms our
bathrooms that contain, you know showers or baths.
Now one thing you'll notice is that these numbers.
are normalized
so no value goes between no everybody every
numbers between 0 and 1.
of course the way we can normalize this data using
scikit learn
Cyclone is a library for machine learning.
But this data this this state has been normalized.
So for example
If let's say one of the let's say we have one
property that has six.
Bathrooms, it's a very spacious house.
Cup Penthouse or something?
then
if when we normalize it or if you
if we if we normalize that this will be this will have
the number one.
the highest number of full bathrooms
So if you want to know how many or yeah if
you want to know for example, how many bathrooms?
This apartment has you will multiply six by
zero point.
one to five
Okay, this is not even one. So I think the part I
think the property with the most.
Number of bathrooms was something like 8 or 10.
I have to look at the original data.
But you get the idea.
Yeah.
And suppose we have one that same property
had four stories. That was a very large house. So 0.35. Well,
that's just the one story house.
Now we did some data cleaning before
we got this. So if you see here this data set is called how data
set.
house data set
scaled
so in this notebook in this Jupiter notebook, I'm skipping
the
data cleaning part
Anyway, this is the this is an end dimensional data
as you can see. It's so big that it cannot even
fit and we have these three dots.
I think
there were I don't know they were
definitely more than 20.
Columns this Matrix. So it's a very large Matrix.
For this we would PC would be very helpful.
Anyway, that's the data set. We can review with the
word pandas.
and
let me skip to discussion about labels and features because
we haven't talked about yet.
And let me skip the train test split part. Let me show you how
to create a sequence of neural networks.
So here what we do is we have the sequential class and we
know classes because classes begin with
an uppercase letter.
Anytime you see some function or a
variable spelling uppercase. That's a
class.
Which means we can instantiate it and this will become an object
and what we do what we know about what we know of an object
is that they have attributes and properties.
So one of the properties of the sequential object is
at
So here we're adding a densely connected.
Excuse me.
a dense
input layer
we have
63 inputs
and 50
outputs so if I go to that slide
If you see here.
We are talking about.
this part
so we have 63 Dimensions here. We
have Harmony to me here the input dimensions are what one two,
three, four, five six, seven eight.
And the output dimensions are one two, three, four, five
six, seven eight nine.
So input dimensions are eight output. Dimensions are 9.
Now there is by the way, there is no precise formula
for deciding the number of output dimensions.
And there are some experimentation involved.
Tensorflow has something called the tensor playground,
which is a very nice visual way for
you to see how neural networks work. But again
because we don't have much time. I'm going to leave that for later session anyway.
input dimensions
I'll put Dimension. So we we actually create the first hidden
layer and the first input layer in tensorflow.
In one goal. Okay, so here
This is the first input layer and the head layer in one go.
So the input Dimensions the number of incoming.
features and the number of perceptions
Activation function like cardio. I'm really sorry about this. I don't mind.
It's very sensitive activation function. Like I told you is how you
process the signal.
the value the rectified
linear something. I forgot the name.
is used
is actually a very
effective activation function
But in order for me to show you why it's affected by we have to
leave that for a separate session.
Well, let me just run this as quickly as I can. So the
first
input slash hidden layer
And then the other hidden layers.
So this one has this one will receive.
A 50 inputs from the previous layer and
output 100 layers.
Why 100 because we want to learn as many ways as we can.
And then another hidden layer and then file the
upper layer and here we can see we've set the output to one.
Why one well because we want a single value we
want a single.
numeric
estimate
for any given property
you can see here. We once we have created a
sequence of layers. We will then compile it.
then we have
A loss function again, the loss function is how
we evaluate the prediction quality of this model.
We said that we want the MSU the converge to zero.
So if you see here.
When we train it.
It's a scientific notation. It says 0.00.
0 1 7 7 160
and as
it keeps on learning.
you can see the MSC starts to
grow smaller so you can see this and went from
E minus zero fourth e minus zero
five, so that's one more zero next to it.
so it's even closer and closer to zero every
Progression of time sometimes it will go up a little bit. But ultimately.
It should converge to zero.
If it does not conversion zero and it's instead it
diverges. Well, then there was something wrong with the code
you've done.
Okay.
anyway
This is how we this is one metric by what you
will determine the quality of the model. That's MSC. And then
there's something called the optimizer algorithm the atom
algorithm again. I'm not gonna talk about it here. It's in that video. I told you
about it has to do with gradient descent.
Let me scroll down some more.
So after we evaluate the metrics
for the data.
We can see for the training data set. It is 0.0.
well
That's 5073.
So it's very close to zero. This is a good this is a good model.
And for test that it's even smaller still.
For tests, it's even smaller still.
Have you as anyone heard of overtrained overfitting underfitting?
anybody else if you've not heard of overfitting an
underfitting type and in the chip
now very quickly. The reason we use training test
is to quickly identify over affirming
underfitting.
I reason to underfitting is when the model has not learned
anything in particular.
And you can detect underfitting at the training
stage. So if the number is high.
You don't even to proceed the test dataset.
It's already bad.
The way you will detect a overfitting is where you
have a good.
training metric
But then for the test metric it does worse.
So if your training metric is here, which
is that's a good this is good and then it goes up that's overfitting.
If it's high to start with that's underfitting.
So that's why we need to look at training test.
And then once we've done this we have created for ourselves a machine
learning model looking pretty.
You can see here using the predict method.
And then this is the final price.
of one particular property
So what we're
going to do is I'm going to post this notebook with
some additional comments in the dashboard.
Before we get into our next session. I strongly recommend.
that if you're not familiar with
test dataset train dataset
machine learning metrics and the grading this in
a particular that you watch that video.
The video is called mathematics for machine learning you may have.
Attended the event and there are also timestamps so
you can jump to the section that is relevant to you.